barton thorne is a high school principal
at cordova high school in tennessee
after the riot at the capitol on january
6th barton thorn noticed that some of
the country's most powerful
companies had begun a campaign of mass
censorship
twitter and youtube deleted accounts
they didn't like including the
president's accounts
amazon google and apple forced parlor
off the internet entirely
that's when barton thorne decided to
deliver this video message
to his students twitter facebook google
and apple
are so powerful and they have
unilaterally made a decision of what you
can and cannot see
on their platforms um that's a major
issue and i want you to understand that
i want you to understand the problem
that's going to face you and your
generation
if there is no longer a marketplace of
free exchange of ideas
every word of that is true
no one can credibly claim otherwise it's
factually correct
but for the crime of criticizing silicon
valley
the publicly traded monopolies that
control our intellectual life
for doing that barton thorne was
suspended by shelby county school
district
he then followed the lawsuit and was
immediately reinstated barton thorne is
a brave man he joins us now with his
attorney
daniel sur thank you both for coming on
mr thorne first to you
um what was the justification for
suspect i mean i thought we were allowed
to criticize whatever we want
but criticizing billion-dollar
monopolies that control
speech that is now a crime in shelby
county what did they say to you
uh well thank you tucker for having me
uh and first i want to say i'm i'm here
as a just a private concerned citizen
not in any official capacity uh as a
principal
um but you know when we uh when all this
came out
you know i i give a monday message to
all of my students i try to
encourage them motivate them challenge
them to think and this just seemed to be
an appropriate topic
um and so yeah there was a few people
that made some anonymous complaints and
and when i
uh was was asked about it uh i
specifically asked what
uh what was it that i said what's the
issue let's talk about it and what was
told to me was it really wasn't what i
said it was when i said it and the
timing of
it so i never really got that answer but
uh we were just
you know we're just really concerned
about uh where this is going and where
it's heading
uh that that just a a regular old person
like me
can just espouse american values and
what's been
core to our country for for hundreds of
years
um and somehow now that's taboo and off
limits
uh so we're just really concerned about
that not really
um willing to lay down about this one
so i want to ask your attorney a legal
question sir is is
criticizing google a fireable offense
now in the united states
of course not tucker this is one of the
most blatant
examples of cancel culture that we have
seen in our country to date
and the irony here is that principal
thorne
was telling his students about the
dangers of cancer culture
about the speech police that come after
regular everyday people and he's the one
who ends up getting cancelled
it's i i hope you sue these people into
oblivion
i really you don't have to comment on
that but that is my fervent hope i'm
grateful that you came on tonight it's
one of the most shocking stories i think
we've ever put on the show
thank you both
thanks for having us if it can happen to
him it can happen to anyone amen
god speed you should fight back